y hoy es un día muy importante para una
persona halle berry él es el presidente
de esta corte especial que se ha
constituido para juzgar este terrible
caso de los atentados del 13 de
noviembre es un juez muy experimentado
él tiene 65 años 40 de carrera y de
hecho es su último juicio es el tercer
juicio terrorista que le toca a él
presidir y porque es un día importante
porque tiene que leer el informe el
resumen que ha hecho después de leer
esos 500 más de 500 tomos de esta
investigación él ha pasado ya un año y
medio dedicado en exclusiva a este caso
nos va a contar lo que pasó
lamentablemente ese 13 de noviembre y
también nos va a contar quiénes son los
acusados se prevé que dure 8 horas esta
lectura por lo mismo va a ser ayudado
por dos de sus asesores que por cierto
son también jueces raúl y si no esta
mañana también han pasado los testigos
ayer recordemos terminó la constitución
de las partes civiles muchas personas
que no están en esas 1800 acusaciones
civiles que se consideran víctimas de
estos ataques y que están pidiendo
también ser parte de este juicio la
decisión definitiva se va a conocer el 4
de octubre entre las personas por
ejemplo que se consideran víctimas el
baterista del grupo que tocaba esa noche
en el bataclán el grupo eagles of death
metal él y su esposa quieren ser también
partes civiles las personas que están
como decíamos pasando ahora son los
testigos es lo mismo hay que controlar
su dirección su nombre todos sus datos
es el juez que tiene también que hacer
esa tarea tan tediosa raúl así es erika
un juicio que pues es denominado del
siglo en francia y también que va a
durar nueve meses nada menos